Sal Con here from Khan Academy and we
are inside uh my office SL closet this
is where I record videos take meetings
Etc uh many of yall know I'm a big fan
of meditation it helps me clear my mind
it helps me think more clearly be less
stressed etc etc and I'll show you where
where I meditate so I actually usually
meditate on this chair this is like my
my meditation chair and I like it cuz
it's it's nice and firm so I try to do
it before the family wakes up uh when
the house is quiet
and yeah I'll just uh sit here get nice
posture and uh you know close my eyes
and deepen my breaths and put a smile on
my face I feel like that um actually put
you in a better mood if you force a
smile and then uh you know just try to
Ste steal my thoughts accept everything
around me steal my thoughts and
[Music]
uh I started only doing 10 minutes a day
but I found after a month I was just
getting less stressed I was sleeping
better I was able to focus a lot better
I was listening to people better I know
it sounds like it defies the laws of
time mathematics but if you do that
meditation for 10 or 20 minutes you're
eerily going to find yourself with more
time because you realize that you're
going to focus on the things that matter
you're going to be able to pay more
attention and you're just going to be
doing things in a more sustainable way
it's you know take it for what it's
worth but it's it's definitely been
working for me